hello everyone
to all the students who have managed to
do well in je Mains and Jay Advanced a
big congratulations
at this important juncture when you are
about to go to college there are a
number of important things which you
must remember and must understand so in
this video I am going to share three
quick tips with you regarding those
important points first and foremost
this is not the time to relax it may
seem a little bit counter-intuitive to
you because all this while all of your
elders all of your parents seniors
everyone has been telling you that just
give this last-ditch effort after that
you can relax but my personal advice to
you is that this is not the time to
relax
okay just think about it right now your
josa counseling is going on
so this is I'm making this video on July
2nd
but
after you join College your first
mid-semester examinations are going to
be held sometime around mid semester mid
September
so you see
only in about two and a half months time
you're going to sit for your first
examination until now it is not even
properly decided which department you
are going to which Institute you are
going to so you do not have the luxury
to relax right now the time to relax
will come after the first semester is
over and certainly after the first year
is over you will get a proper summer
vacation after that and you'll be the
first batch after the pandemic which is
not going to have a staggered system
compared to the other batches will have
a proper summer vacation the proper time
to relax will be then not now you have a
certain momentum going on continuing
from your J Mains and Jay Advanced you
have to maintain that and you have to
perform well based on that momentum in
the first semester
I've seen a lot of students who take it
a little bit easy in the first semester
after after getting completely tired
from their entrance examination
preparation and then they they don't
even realize that the exams are up on
them and then they do not perform well
and that creates a kind of Benchmark for
them and it sometimes goes a little bit
downhill from there people have
recovered from there but why go down
that route so my suggestion is keep up
the momentum and perform well and then
relax
the second point is that
suppose you are in a situation where uh
you are not getting your preferred
Department
I'm not talking about the Institute but
you're not getting the profit Department
okay maybe the kind of Department uh
you're getting is somewhat down the list
of your preference maybe you're getting
your third choice or your fourth choice
or maybe even less
now in this situation it is very natural
for you to feel a little bit despondent
okay after all this hard work tremendous
effort maybe had dropped also after all
this extreme hard work you're still not
getting what you want okay well that is
part of being an adult
okay so welcome to adulthood
but uh on a more uh immediate
immediately actionable kind of thing
what I would suggest is that see this
kind of a despondency is not really
healthy it is rather very toxic and uh
see you uh so the the biggest
preparation that you have had through
your entrance examination is problem
solving so why don't you treat like this
situation also like a problem
okay the you try to identify try to
diagnose why this feeling of despondency
why this feeling of sadness okay is it
not perhaps only because of so much
media hype going around certain
departments why don't you try to find
out for yourself through your own
research what the department that you
are getting actually through the josa
counseling what it is all about try to
find out the kinds of career
opportunities that are there try to find
out the people who have managed to do
well
okay I'm I can assure you this that when
you take a completely educated look
about your department which you're
getting you will be always always very
pleasantly surprised the kind of feeling
that you will have is that oh my god I
didn't even know this kind of a thing
could be done in my department and I am
seeing this as my department okay
because it is going to be your
department on that note
there will be certain people
okay neighborhood Aunts Uncles these
kinds of people who are always big
experts okay self-appointed experts uh
who will make certain kinds of comments
okay oh my God why are you taking this
department oh my God you have gotten
this department so this is a dead
Department there is no scope all of
these things
so the best way to deal with these kinds
of remarks is to just smile at them and
then move away you do not even have to
respond to them because most of these
remarks are completely uneducated
because if you were to really argue with
them
if if I were there supposed to defend
you the kind of question I would have
asked is that how much do you really
know about the department that you think
that the student would like to go to and
how much do you think you know about the
department that the student is actually
going to on both discounts I am sure
they will come up blank their expertise
so to speak quote unquote expertise is
also based on some kind of media hype
that they get to hear
so I'm very sorry to say this but they
really do not know so you do not have to
listen to them
furthermore
I have found out okay that so this has
been my biggest Learning lesson from my
YouTube Journey
that whenever people make some kind of
negative remarks some kind of toxic
remarks uh some comments like that
the best way to deal with that is to let
them drown in the insignificance of
their own mediocrity
just don't respond
okay so I'll just leave it at that I'm
sure you'll understand now uh another
very important thing related to this
second Point only is that if you are
getting a department and uh it is now
more or less locked that this is going
to be your department and this is really
not your Preferred Choice by any any
means uh
still I would say OK still I would say
that when you are going to take your
admission when you finally go to The
Institute to take your admission go
through the formalities please do this
and I don't even know how to put this in
English Okay so I'll use a Hindi word
for it because that's the best way to
express it please do this with a little
bit of shraddha in your heart okay maybe
a little bit of a what I would say like
a like a pure devotion in your heart
because if while taking admission you do
not have that shraddha that devotion in
your heart and the feeling that you have
is some kind of a negative feeling some
you kind of where from the very first
you you want to uh you want to get
admitted to the Institute but you want
to escape somehow somehow escape from
the Department it is that kind of of a
negativity is actually going to bite you
back very very seriously okay except the
department that you are getting try to
find out the best things that are there
okay and there are very very good things
no matter what the department is you
just don't know about it okay try to
find out the best things about it and
deal with it like an adult instead of
just trying to run away from it
the next point which is very very
important is that
suppose
it has so happens that you have gotten
your preferred Department maybe you have
also gotten an Institute which is
very famous okay maybe you have gotten
into one of the older iits everyone
wants to get into that
and the department also is maybe some
kind of a circuitable branching but
extremely happy about it your parents
are absolutely proud about it good very
good you also be proud about it but do
not by any means be arrogant about it
okay there is a world of difference
between being proud okay which is
absolutely okay you have to you you
deserve to be proud of your
accomplishments but do not be arrogant
about it okay because try to realize
this that
even if maybe you were not able to do
one or two problems that difference of a
few marks would have caused a huge
difference in the in the rank that you
got
so
I mean be grateful for what you have
obtained
okay
it could have been a completely
different picture just by a few marks so
you absolutely do not have any right to
be arrogant or to look down on on others
who have probably not gotten the uh
their preferred departments and please
also remember this is very very
important
today
at the time of Jose counseling when the
jail results are out and everything you
are feeling like you are on the top of
the world
uh because of your high rank
but one year down the line two years
down the line even people who were much
lower in rank they may start
outperforming you
okay so once you reach the Institute
once the actual study start of the
actual the actual undergraduate
curriculum
the real battle will start I'm sure you
have heard about all of this from some
of your seniors maybe some teachers the
real battle will start after you start
your undergraduate curriculum and then
you will realize that none of these all
India ranks this all this Fame from your
uh from your je performance Will Survive
okay the only thing that is going to
survive and persist is how you perform
actually during your undergraduate
education okay so as I said in the first
point
do not relax okay you will you will get
time to relax there will be moments of
it as you become older and older you
will realize when to relax when not to
relax but in the very first semester
don't do that and uh certainly uh keep
up the momentum in a very humble fashion
uh you have done well keep on doing well
this is my wish to you all the very best
and uh until you reach College where it
is uh guarantee that the food will not
be good enjoy your mom's cooking okay so
all the very best carry on